from Creature features to gritty War
Stories these movie series have been
cranking out low budget sequels for a
surprisingly long time a divisive
Crucible of infernal frights Clive
Barker's directorial debut Hellraiser is
regarded as either a miracle of movie
horror or an overly bloody mess
depending on who you ask is it possible
for both to be true regardless of the
film's quality which is mostly fine
pellraiser is undeniably visually
striking debuting Pinhead in the
cenobites in this gnarly vision of
industrial hell but if there's any
debate about the quality of the original
there's little to none about the
following nine sequels Hellbound
Hellraiser 2 is a pretty good time but
after that they're awful in all sorts of
interesting ways we have such sights to
show you once an anthology film that was
edited into an incoherent mess tried the
fourth installment Hellraiser bloodline
an unrelated script that was grafted
onto the series with little relation to
what came before try the incredibly
poorly named Hellraiser debtor the
series didn't go direct to DVD and truly
off the rails until the fifth
installment 2000's Hellraiser Inferno
but sequels continued and we also got a
less soulless and more thoughtful remake
film in 2022
released in 1990 Tremors is a classic
Creature Feature that you've probably
stumbled upon while flipping channels
across basic cable starring Kevin Bacon
and Fred Ward as a couple of handymen in
the Down and Out town of perfection
Nevada it's an engaging and Charming
film featuring some very memorable
tunneling worm creatures with appetites
for human flesh with such impressive
talent and solid practical effects it's
no wonder that Tremors spawn to hold
direct video film series and even a
short-lived television show though Fred
Ward returned for 1996's not bad tremors
2 aftershocks succeeding entries saw
diminishing returns weather was the
introduction of flying Raptor variations
of the series monsters and Tremors 3
back to Perfection or forgettable
Western prequels set in 1889 none of
them ever matched the explosive fun of
the original in 2015 a fifth sequel was
released co-starring Jamie Kennedy that
one isn't all that terrible though the
quality of the films may be uneven it's
quite admirable that throughout all
these installments and even the TV show
actor Michael Gross always shows as the
absurdly well-prepared survivalist Bert
Gummer the fun that gross has in the
role is simply infectious
all you really need to know about the
original leprechaun released in 1993 is
that a pre-friend Jennifer Aniston is in
it a fact the marketing team got a lot
of mileage out of on the film's eventual
DVD release these movies have always
been schlock among schlock puzzling at
best has anyone ever found leprechauns
to be scary still the teams that have
worked on the various leprechaun films
at least deserve credit for hitting
every single horror movie Trope setting
over the years the leprechaun went to
Vegas the leprechaun went to space the
leprechaun went to the hood and it was
actually pretty good the leprechaun then
went back to the hood and it was not a
seventh installment the first one
without original Star Warwick Davis
crawled out of the direct to video
gutter for a brief theatrical release
and near Universal rejection in 2014.
that still didn't stop the leprechaun
from returning in Leprechaun returns
four years later but Davis didn't appear
in that one either and it aired on the
Sci-Fi Network it seems this leprechaun
hasn't seen a big pot of gold in quite
sometime and I know you did
the original Jarhead released during the
height of the painful and questionable
Iraq war was a gritty realistic personal
movie about the private hell of armed
conflict it wasn't marked by big
explosions in combat but rather the
existential angst and Terror that comes
during the moments in between it was all
set in a surreal Sandy landscape that
would be beautiful if it didn't invite
so much dread directed by Sam Mendes in
collaboration with legendarily talented
cinematographer Roger deakins the movie
is gorgeous Stark and unlike any War
film you've seen this side of Apocalypse
Now it's simply great plain and simple
and then there are the sequels nine
years later from the director of Lake
Placid the Final Chapter in Company of
Heroes came Jarhead 2 Field of Fire then
there's Jarhead 3 The Siege and Jarhead
law of return which were so bad they're
barely worth talking about so we won't
if the Brendan Fraser Mummy Trilogy was
like the hit TV comedy Ensemble friends
then the spin-off Mythology series it
gave birth to The Scorpion King is like
the Joey of Egyptian flavored early
2000s action horror introduced in 2001's
The Mummy Returns The Scorpion King was
a whole King's silent heel played by
Dwayne The Rock Johnson in the early
stages of his acting career back when
people still weren't sure what he was
capable of though the movie wasn't
reviewed well the rock earned positive
attention as a Conan with Charisma
figure and he has since built a career
in Hollywood off of that initially
underestimated reputation surprisingly
the franchise he kicked off is still
chugging along as well with a style that
seems to get more busy more golden and
more like a Mortal Kombat knockoff with
every success of go the 2017 remake of
The Mummy may have been a flop but could
things be different for the Scorpion
King we'll just have to wait and see but
if the answer is no we're not too broken
up about it nothing lasts forever my
king
that is the destiny of all kingdoms
fans of the science fiction film
Starship Troopers may be unaware of how
old the franchise actually is the source
material for the Epic Tale Of Man vs
giant alien bug was a 1959 novel written
by Robert a Heinlein while the first
adaptation of the story was a 1988
six-part anime meanwhile the 1997 film
has built a legacy of controversy
analysis and debate thanks to its sharp
inviting satire regardless of it all
Starship Troopers has become an
Unstoppable franchise that extends to
the present with a reboot rumored to
still be in development there is a
surprising amount of Starship Troopers
content available including video games
an animated series and 5 feature-length
films the first two sequels here of the
Federation and Marauder were direct to
video projects Marauder managed
surprisingly decent reviews thanks to
the return of Casper Van Deen as beloved
bug killer Johnny Rico two additional
animated films Invasion and traitor of
Mars are must watches for only the most
die-hard of fans
there's nothing in the rules that says a
dog can't play basketball and there's no
rule that says that same dog can't spark
a massive franchise in the process
either from its humble start in 1997 as
a feel-good family movie about a canine
athlete and the boy who befriends him
air buds Evolution was slow at first
there was the traditional sequel
released in theaters in which the dog
plays football in the New Millennium he
learned how to play soccer baseball and
finally volleyball all of which made
sense to varying degrees this could have
easily gone on forever until someone had
the brilliant idea to leave the sports
behind as well as anything resembling
reality in 2006 Air Buddies introduced
talking dogs and suddenly all bets were
off over the next seven years the
Buddies faced some serious snow went to
space did Halloween made a lateral
career move into archeology gained
superpowers and met Santa Santa Buddies
then split into its own Universe with a
prequel called The Search for Santa Paws
and a sequel with the surprisingly
serious subplot about a widower and his
children the world of Air Bud is
honestly one of the most confusing
cinematic universes out there the last
airbuddy's adventure was released back
in 2013 but there's still time for the
Buddies to broaden their Horizons Broad
in our Horizons we're lost in space dog
I think our Horizons are broad enough
the original 1997 Anaconda film about an
oversized snake terrorizing a
documentary crew in the Amazon
rainforest was a forgettable project
released amidst The Barrage of killer
creature movies including bats deep blue
sea and Lake Placid although it boasted
an All-Star 90s cast including Jennifer
Lopez Owen Wilson Jon Voight and Ice
Cube the film has been generally panned
for its cookie cutter characters
delivered with half-hearted performances
despite being nominated for six Razzie
Awards the movie did well at the box
office against the moderate budget of
course Hollywood could never leave well
enough alone with the snake movie that
exceeded expectations and they didn't
hesitate to bleed the Creature Feature
dry Anaconda offers an unnecessary four
sequels with the second film in the
franchise anacondas the hunt for the
blood orchid being the only one released
in theaters Anaconda 3 and 4 were filmed
back to back for release on the Sci-Fi
channel in 2008 and 2009. finally the
fifth installment also a made for
television production involved a
crossover with another ongoing creature
Series in like Placid vs Anaconda as
misleading as the title may be the
Amazonian snake does not fight a body of
water but rather the giant crocodiles
from the similar franchise but Anaconda
is still not done as is the case with so
many other 90s franchises a reboot is in
the works
the original home alone is a cherished
Christmas film beloved by audiences of
all ages everything about the first film
fell perfectly into place it was written
and directed by Cinema Legends John
Hughes and Chris Columbus it featured a
young charismatic Macaulay Culkin and it
even had an unforgettable score from
composer John Williams somehow these
creators were even able to recreate the
magic with the sequel Home Alone 2 lost
in New York unfortunately Home Alone was
not a gift that kept on giving
[Music]
holiday classic may be unaware that the
home alone franchise now extends across
six movies some more forgettable than
others 1997's Home Alone 3 was fortunate
enough to feature a script from John
Hughes but it was otherwise a broad
departure from The Originals where the
made for television Home Alone 4 went
wrong was in its decision to recast
original characters like Kevin
McAllister and the wet Bandits without
anybody from the original films taking
part in the production the fifth film
the Holiday Heist was equally
forgettable even if it did have Malcolm
McDowell in it when Disney got their
hands on the franchise more effort was
put into the direct-to-streaming sequel
home sweet home alone unfortunately the
critically panned sixth installment
ultimately destroyed the chances of the
potential Ryan reynolds-led cannabis
infused Home Alone remake stoned alone
long before superhero films were
dominating theaters across the country
the crow was one of the first successful
projects based on a comic book not named
Superman unfortunately the movie is
entwined with the tragedy of star
Brandon Lee's onset death as he was
fatally wounded while filming however
the feature received positive reviews
and has since become a classic for its
dark visual tone in production design
the story of a resurrected musician said
on Vengeance spawned an entire franchise
that includes three sequels and a
short-lived television series
unfortunately each of the movies
released set the franchise further back
culminating in the critically derided
the crow Wicked prayer many fans still
hope for the crow to fly to its former
Heights musician Rob Zombie once
intended to make his directorial debut
with the crow 2037 while rapper DMX also
missed out on a potential the crow
project thankfully there is still hope
for the franchise as a remake of the
1994 film starring Bill Skarsgard is
soon to be released
groundbreaking for its era the original
The Land Before Time released in 1988
was a children's movie with serious
Hollywood power behind it directed by
animation Legend Don Bluth it also
featured Steven Spielberg and George
Lucas as executive producers a moderate
success upon its release the story about
a group of displaced young dinosaurs
grew to gigantic proportions releasing
new sequels far beyond what was
necessary the first Land Before Time
sequel actually wasn't released until
six years after the original and neither
Bluth Spielberg nor Lucas were attached
to the project regardless the franchise
began releasing a new movie almost
annually until 2007 along with a
short-lived animated series that aired
on Cartoon Network Land Before Time
simply could not be stopped with The
Land Before Time 14 journey of the Brave
releasing in 2016. although rumored to
be the final film in the dino-sized
collection it's easy to Imagine The Land
Before Time franchise carrying on until
they run out of Roman numerals for the
titles
the story of what happened at 112 Ocean
Avenue has become more than a legend
it's a paranormal Dynasty that has
outgrown its humble beginnings the
original story as fictionalized in J
Hansen's 1977 novel The Amityville
Horror involves a young family moving
into a colonial home in Amityville New
York before quickly being forced to
abandon it after some paranormal events
the original book received its own
literary sequels but nothing compares to
the number of movies spun off from the
haunted residential home the original
Amityville horror movie was released in
1979 and since then there has been a
smorgasbord of remakes sequels and
satires there are so many Amityville
features that it is nearly impossible to
keep track of them obviously some are
less faithful to the source material
than others like Amityville Karen about
an entitled Karen who becomes possessed
by the Paranormal house
to be jogging these streets are made for
cars
regardless it is safe to say that low
budget Amityville movies are and may
forever be a consistent element of B
grade horror
the 2003 slasher film Wrong Turn was a
horror movie nobody expected much from
the story of three cannibal Brothers
lurking in the forests of the
Appalachian Mountains who capture and
kill a group of young hikers the movie
did moderately well both critically and
financially of course any success for a
horror movie instantly means the sequel
is on the way however the franchise that
was spawned from the original film is
nothing short of unexpected there are
currently seven movies based on the
grizzly Story the most recent being the
2021 reboot originally titled wrong turn
the foundation the this latest
installment reimagines most of the tale
with members of a centuries-old cult
becoming the main antagonist the other
five sequels featured the same
horrifying Brothers three-finger
Sawtooth and one eye who terrorized
Eliza Dushku in the original
who wouldn't love a story about a
Troublesome yet lovable Saint Bernard
who wins over the hearts of its adoptive
family while causing chaos around their
home what if they made that into eight
movies and what if the dog landed an
acting job uncovered lost treasure and
was voiced by Tom Arnold the Beethoven
franchise has certainly grown bigger
than a cumbersome pet since its humble
beginnings in the inaugural 1992 family
comedy originally written by celebrated
filmmaker John Hughes under a pseudonym
as he didn't even want to be associated
with the project Beethoven was a
Charming film that managed to rake in
the money so of course Hollywood had to
suck the Beloved franchise bone dry it
could be argued that Beethoven's Second
was a faithful in worthwhile sequel but
things definitely went downhill from
there the third installment featured a
cross-country road trip followed by a
fourth movie involving a collection of
new pet friends and by the seventh film
Beethoven was being dubbed over by Tom
Arnold in helping to save Christmas you
know Beethoven you must be really famous
because it seems like every person that
lays eyes on you is just left yeah I've
done a few things much like the
energetic Saint Bernard himself the
Beethoven series is out of control
this is one franchise that no one was
asking for but it's shot for the Stars
nonetheless when the original sniper was
released in 1993 critics praised its fun
approach to a classic style of
psychological Thriller however it was
consistently noted as being unoriginal
or shallow for the most part it seemed
like sniper had been discharged until
almost 10 years later when it came back
for a sequel that formed a b grade
franchise that simply won't stop there
are now 9 movies in the sniper franchise
with a tenth reportedly on the way
somehow most of the low budget films
have managed to maintain many of the
stars from the inaugural feature
including Billy Zane and Tom Behringer
still each of the subsequent direct to
video sequels continued to be buried
deep in the Bargain Bin with the latest
installment 2022's sniper Rogue Mission
flying heavily under the radar of most
media Outlets whether anybody is
watching or not it seems as if sniper
has many more stories to tell
Jaws isn't the only shark movie that's
been run ashore with unnecessary sequels
released 24 years after Steven
Spielberg's classic deep blue sea was
another moderately successful 90s movie
that's perhaps best remembered for the
scene where Samuel L Jackson is eaten by
a gigantic shark and we're gonna find a
way to get out of here
first we're gonna seal off this
for the longest time deep blue sea
remained a standalone project embraced
by action fans however Hollywood can
never resist a Revival and in 2018 they
began building a franchise out of
everyone's second favorite shark movie
Deep Blue C2 and deep blue C3 are both
direct to video films that carry on the
story of the genetically modified sharks
introduced in the first movie
surprisingly the sequels are adored by
fans and critics alike in particular the
R-rated deep blue C3 has earned itself a
respectively fresh Rotten Tomato score
even if they did miss the opportunity to
call it deep blue 3. there's no report
of a fourth film in the franchise quite
yet but somebody out there just has to
be planning a new installment that's
deeper and Bluer than ever before
[Music]
thank you